okay
well good afternoon councillors um it's
not quite four o'clock but
we've got everybody attending so i think
we might make a start so
welcome along and i'll declare the
august
2020 council meeting
be in session and
ask for any apologies but there are none
so we'll move on then to
declaration of council conflict of
interest if there's any interests here
that you'd like to register at this
point in time
it's not thank you
move on into the confirmation of the
minutes and the reports from previous
meetings
first one is confirmation of the minutes
the ordinary meeting of council held
tuesday 14 july 2020 would somebody like
to move that be seen as true and correct
record
council grant senator thank you council
read
uh is there any alteration required to
that record
that's the hostage yeah thank you russia
um just item nine goal health
uh building consent p waver um i just
made the point of the hospital being a
charity and
non-profit organization the minutes
haven't captured that and i think that's
a key
key difference that probably the minute
should capture so it's important
so that'll be recognized in the text of
of conversation at the time
and there's nothing further i'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
aye against motion just carried thank
you councillors so we'll move on into
confirmation of the report of the
strategy committee held on wednesday
august so firstly if we can um
leave it as true and correct someone
would like to move that they'd be seen
as a true and correct record
of the meeting councillor mcfarland
thank you i have a second
of that one councillor grant thank you
is there any alteration required
uh to that report yes phillips
uh the recommendation that said that the
council note that confirmed funding of
foreign in a rough order cost of 5.5
million
for the project um all through the
meeting
i legitimate that we were to remove that
5.5 million
project
that was part of the
recommendation that we removed that 5.5
billion
aspect is that we can't confirm
a number of costs until such time
[Music]
[Music]
that's what we were trying to say
5.5 was just a figure pulled out of the
air
based on square meters but we were
looking for plans from architects
that were based around a budget of
four million dollars for the project i
think um
from from my memory um to me if i'm
wrong
that that particular recommendation was
altered to reflect council notes
confirmed funding the
four million dollars and the rest of it
was deleted
correct is that right yeah yeah yeah 5.5
wasn't here
okay so um is that
um
so do we get the opportunity to comment
um
yeah when we discuss the items or the
recommendations thank you
um okay if there's not i'll put the
motion of all those in favor
please say hi hi thanks the motion is
carried that will be seen as a true and
correct record of that one alteration
okay so um the recommendations contained
in the report somebody like to move that
they've been seen
may be adopted counselor
dixon thanks to louis
uh that is open for any alteration that
might be required or any discussion
and the council endorses engagement of
the design team utilized for this
administration building upgrade for this
project and engagement
management project managers and
recommendations
things have changed since moments come
in
competition in that area for the lack of
projects but i'm not sure
[Music]
i think with project management we've
adopted a very much
a horses for courses approach
no different to what if you are
selecting someone to perhaps
a legal firm to represent your interests
signal management have been
from my memory selected without a
competitive process but based on past
performance
um for the past probably 20 years
spanning projects as diverse as
the multi-sports complex the art gallery
the john running room extension
the tara community centre uh the mvm
industrial hub
which is a complex project all of which
have been delivered to council
satisfaction
and gives you a high degree of
confidence uh on that basis
that was why the invitation made you to
select this group
and no one designed that commentary
transplant themselves from next door and
put themselves into this particular
facility with well-established
relationships and
any lessons learned from next door can
be um imported into this project
that's the rationale behind it thank you
um so i think
i understand what you're what you're
saying counselor guard
just i on see there's probably a lot of
those companies have probably been quite
competitive at the moment for this sort
of work
yeah i just wanted everyone if people
commented on a meeting or whether it was
just
a favorite journal
[Music]
but i guess it's a quite a significant
spend on the budget line that doesn't
get competitively kicked so
is there an alternative way of actually
just checking that we're getting value
for money and how do you really measure
that of course but i think it is
you know if you look at the project next
door
the amount we paid a signal is far
greater than we pay a lawyer or an
accountant there's a specialized area so
the timing constraints that you know
providing everything goes well with
consultation
and we go ahead with the project um
um how soon could we go through that
process
and get people up to speed and on board
i guess that's the
worry that i'll have
given there is a quite a tight
some ability to measure and then against
what happens in other projects
how competitive their airlines are this
one is trying to forget
consulting they get a lot of work from
us the standard fee is
x percent i wanted to drop by 25 percent
because you're getting standard word
here that's what it is and i just sit
there looking straight in the eye they
said no
i'd say get someone else that's the way
i do
[Music]
look at some other projects and say you
know from another council and say
what's the money that they pay for a
similar site
so just taking on board the comments
that we've made steve
do you think you can quantify the value
for money that we
are getting um reasonably quickly
from sigma um i'll endeavor to you wish
um i think the the flip side is
um when projects don't go well
um and it grabs
and these things grab headlines when
they don't go well and you said well
look
i took a cheaper competitive option we
decided
we could run it ourselves those type of
sentiments would i think just be drowned
out by the
cacophony of public concern about cost
overruns and so
signal has given me personally as a
chief executive
a lot of comfort over the years that
they've got our
backs and that they cover the risks
uh they work for us uh and generally
speaking they deliver projects on time
and without financial surprise
that's a um a rare commodity in today's
world
council baldwin i think it's a good
question to ask and we're getting value
for money from
the response is you know we've got a
strong pesticide
[Music]
[Music]
as much as you can that's your job
[Music]
good question it's a fair question
let's not assume that we're getting
[Music]
the is let's not
move on then is there anything else
in that report that needs to be
discussed i think this project
through is a very sensitive project
and i've had a lot of people stop me on
the street recently
and i'm not a well-known counselor in
town and asking questions and show
great concern about this project so
rather than have the project
at the community strategy meeting and i
think anything on this project should be
decided by full council
so that's what we're discussing now
as chairman of the community strategy i
think that's a recommendation with pop
quarters
that actually comes back to council for
final decision i think some other
countries are out putting
the cap before the horse here so i think
that the
motion states that
that's the hosting yeah i do agree with
uh
councilman now on this one like it does
have a high level interest probably from
this table and also from the community
and why not and we have the opportunity
to attend the committee we can't always
do that but
you don't get the same level of
information and then you
ask your questions that you're facing
now after the event
so i think do it's right if this could
be an item on the council agenda i think
it's the appropriate place for it then
everyone's got the same information same
time
and i guess if you follow that to a
logical extension you wouldn't have any
committees
you have a committee on the whole for
all the discussions that we have and
sometimes in the past we've had that um
this time around we chose to have
a limited number of committees and give
them a little bit more
authority and scope and
i guess we're just working through that
the ramifications of that now
what we're talking about here is
generally how most councils in the
country across the country function
they'll have committees and some of them
might have four or five six or seven
committees
that are made up of different
councillors rather than
all councils and and
and you get this very discussion at the
council meeting because people who
haven't been partied with discussion
unaware
and i guess that that can happen
um i just i wonder where the cutoff
might be
if we're going to say something
significant or not significant
um what would come to council what would
be the significance
is it just a dollar value i suggest not
i think there's a lot of other things
that could be
deemed significant that would need to
probably need to be
discussed as well so i personally feel
comfortable that
it gets its level of scrutiny it goes
through two meetings before
any of the recommendations become
emotions and in a direction for counsel
so i met the
the will of the council but
unless we can get some sort of direction
uh from council then i think we should
carry on would you like me to move a
motion
just test that or how would you well if
that's what's required
well i i do feel if i can so yeah
i think you're right but i think this is
a single item that we're
singled out and just based on the
feedback i believe it is
and that the full council would like to
consider i may be alone
so let me just explore what that what
that means
in this particular population
um given that we're we are up against a
very tight time frame
an incredibly long time this um
the council decides that they want to be
anybody
around the table to have that input um
do we have a special counsel meeting to
consider this
if necessary i'd like
um but i do think that if that is the
course of counsel then
i need to think very carefully about why
we've got committees
and what is the purpose council grant
thanks for watching
the last century
there are good cases for smaller
companies because they're nimble
um
um we can't all be at all committee
members meetings but
i i do agree with two previous speakers
so can i just um test you on that one
counselor grant what what do you mean by
missing information
well it's not the informational
discussions certainly missing a
discussion
of the meeting i think that's different
to information
so there is a
i do think it's important that we use
the right words here because
that suggests that councils can hold
information and that's not the case
if it is
[Music]
[Music]
i've been on council now this is my 19th
year
um when i first came onto council we had
committees with different members
[Music]
for this term um it was pretty fractious
and we had meetings where
councillors who would not have been and
bear in mind those councillors were
actually invited to be part of those
four days so he would have certainly
councillors on
committees so
i think we've just got to bear in mind
that with big issues that
is
and one of the options to easily fix
this situation would be
all counsellors on the committees um
there's no problem with that at all it
will mean that there's more
meetings for councillors and there's
more time
involved and and the expectation is
next in terms of
committee structures but there's also
the question about this particular item
and this particular item there's one
that has got
quite a tight time frame around it and
i'll
[Music]
it was subject of a phone call from a
senior
senior government officials who asked me
and and was it genuinely shovel ready
application said well there was always a
element around
community spaces that needed a
conversation with the community
but when push came to shove i was asked
when would can construction likely
commence
and i think well potentially it could
happen february next year
but that's on the basis of uh as you see
the timetable in the report that went to
the community strategy committee
an engagement process that runs through
the rest of august
with the development of their view to
getting settlement
on your concept floor plan and um
pricing in october in order to get
uh working drawings developed uh tenders
called
and with hopefully initial um
work being done in february around um
any asbestos that meant that it may need
to be removed from the building
and the building proper we're not
starting to probably that may
but it's very tight we wish
the item is still open for discussion
um three-year worship i understood
um that any counsellor could come into
the meeting so um is this
any different i noticed that um
councilman
now can belong to the community strategy
speaking right um to set a way
to deal with this is that just open it
just given what direction the meeting is
taking now
i think probably we need to analyze this
uh in some way
or rather and
i'm just going to seek some advice and
chief executive here now in terms of
process so it sounds to me
like there's a desire for all
councillors who
committed members of all committees is
that right
i think you worship we just tonight
today we just focus on this
particular issue and all points taken
councils things made around the table
this item
in particular i could be dealt with in
full count two issues
the other one's probably for future
discussions i think it's
it's been highlighted here um by
you know the obvious feeling that some
counselors feel as though they're not
included
in the discussion so i think it's
probably a good time to
address that one as well but in terms of
i take your point the important thing
here is
um it's way too forward with this
particular item
and again i'm going to ask some advice
here but
if if council want to
consider this one separately as a
council
and what do we do with the meetings
always had
um i'm not sure and how soon do we need
to do that probably
testing this week possibly tomorrow
you worship when it comes to a specific
item
the council can always call it up and
say that delegation is
removed and we want that issue coming
for the full council
i don't see any process deficiency if
the council is of a mind to
to do that the wider issue about
the purpose of committees the
performance and function
is a matter for another day and
an agenda item i think
[Music]
time for reflection about how this new
structure's working
and what are the potential or perceived
shortcomings and what are the upsides
that's something that
needs to be taken some time to before
you move and frankly it's not on the
agenda for
discussion tonight but the issue of the
library
and bear in mind now that once you've
passed this resonance
recommendation from the committee
there's no further work required of the
governance arm of council until the
engagement process has been concluded
and that's really about four weeks away
from where we sit
so if i'm asking how do we
there's no suggestion we're going to
undo the work to date of the committee
it's just to go forward position from
here to ensure that
that's his name perceived what's being
intended so uh if that's the case and
that's fine
um but it certainly wasn't the way i
picked it up
so what do we need as council to have
that discussion
well next steps so when when the
design is ready for discussion
as you normally would so it's all
pretty tight so it's not pretty
that is actually a bit outlined in the
information for
today there we were the next step was
going to
which includes consultation process
which i believe has started
today but tomorrow uh it's a short dated
consultation process that also includes
the
uh formation of the plans and community
consultation
um i think that it's actually there
um i think we created some noise around
that that we actually let that step be
taken
and move forward from there and bring it
to the
obviously to the full full council
and can we move it from the community
strategy
committee into full council for the next
step
is that that's the question for your
worship the community strategy committee
is not scheduled to meet again
until november anyway so
um so probably going to be an
extraordinary meeting
of the french committee or straight for
full council
to keep the project momentum going so
it's actually
to that meeting and take it away from
the community strategy group so all
councillors can
uh get all consultation plus the ability
to see all that information
okay that's what i
what needs to change about the
recommendation
the um together with updated costing
design
to two full counts yes
so that's the only change
is
[Music]
in the recommendation but that would be
i mean depending on the type of
feedback you get from the engagement
process um
i always envision there would be some
type of workshop because there may well
be different options as to how to meet
the messaging you received from the
public
that workshop would need to take place
depending on
pricing information that
you may want to have available at the
time of workshop
um i'm picking worship that's probably
going to be somewhere around about
um mid to
the latter heart will mid to later half
of september
okay
okay um so
we note that the final recommendation
from the community strategy committee
be altered to recognise that the
result of engagement will come to full
council
firstly in a workshop scene into a full
council meeting to consider
the way forward
so is there any other operations
required to that
set of motions
it's not and what about
for the rest of that committee there's
two other items like that
is there any alterations there
does not put that motion
uh the mover and the secondary
comfortable
is that i'll put that altered motion all
those in favor please say aye aye aye
thanks promotion is carried
and can we note that
the next council meeting will need to
have a discussion around
committees
what sort of requests we make of
committees
at what level
okay is there any
report
so it needs to be received and adopted
move council folks signal for
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
[Music]
they're struggling with volunteers at
the moment but that's like
most organizations in you know
we're all struggling for volunteers um
we're working we're working with the
group of small groups here at the moment
to see if we could help me out
financially to see if um
we also agreed to open it up to the
wider community
community that is the whole district
rather than just the material district
which
may help them out in this growing season
and we're just taking um
taking a look at um one or two other
options that have been working with the
group
you know that's like so i'm with
councillor background about
it would
okay so we have a mover and a seconder
for
[Music]
there's a lot of money floating around
at the moment
[Music]
um
and i was just wondering what happened
and they can't we can't guarantee that
they're going to turn up every saturday
they're governed by what
um
[Music]
[Music]
apparently not
the some of the members of our community
who continually
scare manga about the situation in
matera
and and i get disarmed every time i see
an article once again in the paper i
think they've got to sit back
and say that the government and this
council
are doing their advice to remove it from
matera
and give them the opportunity to do so
and stop scare motivating the poor
people
um you know i
talked about that in the minutes
when they had a phone call and
when people go and pass taking videos
and then
putting it on social media it just glued
out all that
proportion about what the actual core
was and that's why
i answered that
so i just once again
like to say to the residents on matera
stay calm stay safe and let the
government
and the council do their jobs
certainly the deal that the chief
executive negotiated
is the best deal that was ever going to
be offered
and and to
put obstacles in the way of that taking
place is
um it's not good
so it's not as though we're not doing
anything and that's what annoys me
um okay um put that motion all those in
favor please say all right
on to item seven which is tanker waste
discharge facility
and uh we have a report from waters
network
engineer who's going to leave that
thank you worship um yeah so this is
something
[Music]
a little um it's a specific disposal
facility for um
a tank and way so um specific times
and things like that indeed around the
district
um
[Music]
just looked at a few different options
um and what other councils have
organized and things like that
and there's quite a variety the solution
that we've
identified is trying to optimize our
existing infrastructure down as a
wastewater treatment plant
[Music]
it gives us a lot a lot more ability to
monitor
what's going on what's going into our
wastewater treatment plant and things
like that
um so um
to do it in two phases and that will
allow us to get it up and running
initially
and how we might be able to improve it
um
i guess there is a reasonable cost
associated with implementing the
solutions
to recover their costs uh proposing to
increase the 10 place disposal costs
so we'll be underfunded by the user of
the facility we've done a review of
other councils charging arrangements um
our current charging range was
significantly lower than
other councils are charging so we're
proposing to increase that
it's have you had discussions with the
techa drivers or companies
to discuss the future costs
them with certain discussions around
our proposal to upgrade the
infrastructure
discussion relations
[Music]
yeah so sorry i didn't quite hear that
[Music]
um
i guess uh um the cost is based on
what the actual cost of the facility is
and what's happening in the in the
market in terms of
water is that right and there's
worship yeah
[Music]
i'm sure um
happy to continue what they are but
we're looking at
a really an increased
level of service that
[Music]
costs
so you know i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
otherwise the right players to do it
somewhere along the line that cost will
be passed on to the people who
have benefit from that from that
business
they're mostly going people so
[Music]
just a question matt we've referred so
far to tanker drivers
and the registration of tango drivers
it's not tanker drivers
it's tanks it's operators
yeah sorry
so yeah so it'll be the business that
operates the tanker so there could be
multiple drivers
it's just
i just want to make sure that it's
moderate i mean you know if we're able
to spread it out over a couple years
thank you um councillor actually asked
my
question so the only concern that i
really have
i mean it's all user pays these days and
you're all
at the other end of that but the one-off
registration fee
what is the purpose of that
so let me cover some health and safety
issues as well yes that's correct
hey thank you um
uh you probably just asked answered my
question but the other question i have
is uh in regards to
is this registration going to be open
difficult
operators um just local
free worship yes so that's you know i
guess that's part of the reason
that that was opposing the cost the cost
that we are
um is to make sure that it's full cost
recovery so that
was coming from outside the district we
could be confident that
we're covering those costs and
disregards and funding
just the context this what is a typical
secret tank
holding this costing 25
what what what is that
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
yeah sorry i accept the sentiments
around the table but i just wonder if
we're not chasing
um a significant cost increase when you
look at the frequency
to which a separate tank holder is going
to incur this cost
as opposed to what a normal rate payer
or connected ratepay is paying in terms
of charges for
facility services so
you might have spent um
i think option three is good um normally
when a separate tank has been eaten
there is no
water left in the tank it is full on
solids
um so moving that to the oxidation ponds
is
yeah definitely so at least it's not
going to block up or
do any damage to our wooden street mains
or wherever they go along there
um it is yeah like i said it is normally
just solids
um so the fact that they are emptying it
at the oxidation bonds and we can
solidify it and liquefy it and so it's
better than easier processed
um yeah that's just going through
20 years of experience of playing with
super tanks
um so it and honestly look when you go
unblock a drone or clear a secret tank
people are happy they're just happy
that's gone for sure um
you've got to put down to your hygiene
as well your health and safety
so there's a lot of little factors in
there when it comes to dealing with
so no problems with the pricing
okay council reed thank councilman
um i'm sorry this is not serious but i
was quite
amused to see that the acronym was jim's
truck as opposed to anything else
what's that deliberate okay
did you see that changed
yeah i was thinking about the frequency
it's probably five years since
yeah so every five six seven years
okay
[Music]
the wastewater treatment plant and what
the future of that's going to look like
but the infrastructure that we're
installing here
is about giving trucks access into our
interesting and things like that so that
would certainly
so that's again um
um
okay for the comment or discussion
if not somebody like to move the
recommendations
counselor phillips secondary counselor
lee
is there any discussion on those
recommendations i'll put that all those
invited please say i
i guess the motion is carried
so it takes us on to um long-term plan
and draft
timetable and council will note there's
a
fair bit over here as well do you want
to talk to this one
yeah thank you um
financial officers prepare to schedule
um
based around trying to get us
into position to be able to adopt a
consultation document
by the end of march
next year and you might think oh that's
quite a wee way away but
places are fortnightly workshops that
you signed up for last meeting and
history
tells us that we probably need at least
a dozen workshops
a week's gallup away and given the
appetite of some
for have a deep dive into the revenue
and finance policy
i i'm very confident that you'll need
these two workshops and maybe a third in
there as well
depending on how exploratory you want to
be in terms of
changes to existing policy so
i i reckon we recognize and preparing
the schedule we worship that the first
meeting only this
occurs next tuesday um and
if the 25th of august is set in concrete
because luke blackburn is going to be
doing the
tutorial and that's the only day he's
really available
um but if you were to shy away from
committing to next tuesday we just have
to
roll it all back a week or two and we
might have to catch up later on down the
line
in terms of the timetabling
but and there's certainly fat in the
system in terms of
intensifying the frequency of workshops
uh if on a roll
but i do know from previous ltps that
elected member and senior staff fatigue
can sit in if there's just a rolling
knock them down dragging out a series of
workshops quite intense
[Music]
so these will be put into your calendars
yep
everything always one back to 330.
give it these ones we get all these
put into our calendars so that'll carla
will do that for you
fingers crossed as well
so somebody like to move that be
received and noted yes
mr bulger
uh move on into item nine which is the
grants
subcommittee we have a report here that
needs to be received and recommendations
contained
within the report be ratified
is there any discussion on the report
so the two recommendations are there yep
signal for that
children
so it's moved council grant double
second over there
council read thank you um
is there any discussion it would be
quite good to have a discussion with the
hospital people on how that
funding works a lot of councillors
probably not updating where the
connection between council and hospitals
and
also the political problems that they're
having with funding for the hp
and without their chemical pressure put
on the political side from council
to make that a bit more clearer between
the targets
so to do that in mind and see if we can
organize a meeting because there's a lot
of good stuff going on around there
um lots lot lots of money
did you want to say something yes um
[Music]
um
um
i think it would be certainly be useful
to give the ce
come to um the council but i think
probably
the ce and the board members would be
good to have in a room so we
know they are and um can
fix their sealy glazing glaze on like
this
um
so it's been moved and seconded um the
recommendations contained in page 33
add to that that a meeting between gore
house
limited and inc is that what we're
talking about
the um the organized between
the council and on both those interests
yeah um i just wonder on john's point
whether it would be appropriate that
there's some
something circulated to councillors
before that so they understand what what
council's input is because it's not
entirely clear
the connection just how what are what
are the transactions between us
and how it all works
okay um so we'll just put the emotional
support please say hi
again
uh on to item 10.
um quite a big item um three water
service delivery
form she's got
huge implications for um not just this
council but
the local government into the future and
beyond
um we have a comprehensive
report here from the chief executive you
want to
talk us through that dude
yes thank you this report's turned
mainly modeled on something
standardized and sent around new zealand
for all councils to
um to use so a lot of the languages
but not all has been adopted
with that in mind however it's
i can report that to date i'm aware of
probably about 10 to 12 councils that
already have signed up to the mou
and the important point to emphasize
here is that the
being a secondary does not actually
trigger any
downstream obligation apart to act in
good faith
and to adopt an open mind about what
um aggregation in terms of governance
and management of water of water and
three waters
may mean um there's
an enormous amount of work to tease out
and
instead a lot of us in the sector
there is probably a feeling of
slight unease about how much has been
advanced in terms of agenda and how much
is actually known by the general public
and i think there's maybe a gap
acknowledge there that will need to be
bridged as the
the rubber hits the road in the reform
program uh as we went down down down
this uh
this highway um the real crunch moment
for council is going to be probably that
12 months time
where there will be
some more binding obligations about
entering into
a process they the government has said
that they will be
at this stage accompanied by a financial
incentive
package and we obviously wait with
interest as to what that package
may look like in terms of phase one
package
my report suggested uh well states
there's a 1.1 million dollars as
right and
pretty much also there's another
equal allocation of 1.1 million sitting
in a regional pool to be shared by the
three tlas
that's 1.1 coming to the gorgeous
council
on top of the 1.1 were guaranteed mainly
because of the
heavily flavored suggestion and the
commentary coming from the government
that councils may like to replicate the
regional formula
as per the national formula um
[Music]
i personally think there may be some
other different ways of approaching that
um and it wasn't my suggestion alright
to endorse it of having the chief
executive delegate authority to
negotiate this package
um if that's genuinely been the
direction
nationally mainly i think the government
wants to see
a timely consensus reached about
regional
funding and i suspect they probably
think if they have multiple councils in
the room
together trying to not knock out a
package it might
take some time
but this is a really really
important issue for local government in
new zealand generally
um and
the notion that um
water three waters and stormwater is
still an element of
some uncertainty this stage is really
just
waters and wastewater
to be delivered by um
a pub this day's a preferred outcome as
a public
company servicing multiple regions
uh with a skill-based board of directors
um the key issue i guess for new
zealanders to
to work out is that the ability to
charge
for water and wastewater is a pretty
powerful instrument
and some of us noted during the
workshops to date
20 years ago new zealand's power
industry was
radically reformed and the promise of
cheaper power bills was articulated by
the then energy minister i don't think
too many new zealanders have
encountered lower power bills in the
intervening 20 years
so power water
they are quite similar in terms of their
revenue gathering abilities and
that will be an important factor when it
comes to making the big decisions and
it'll be interesting to see what new
zealanders generally make of
an idea of having control and influence
rested from a local community and
deposited into
a bigger centre somewhere north or south
of where you might
might be residing so they are important
issues that
um in recent times certainly council
amalgamations
those matters have been voted down by
the public
who i think do safeguard intensely
the ability to control a big question i
think coming out your worship of this
will be would be
uh and one of my colleagues has posed
this question just in private
conversation about what is the
what is the problem we're trying to
solve here because if it's money
um councils can put their hand up and
say give us some we'll get on and do it
and certainly
some of the issues this council is
facing my personal view is that
we've got the water supply and quality
issues pretty much
tamed but the wastewater is
another beast altogether um and a lot of
that of course has been driven by
the government in terms of this new um
just released uh national policy
statement on fresh water
and that will pose some real challenges
to both regional and local government
move forward and it's not as if those
challenges are going to be
removed if water is delivered into a
larger regional entity
and if those costs comes onto the entity
they'll have to recover in some way
unless there is generous government
funding so
there's a whole pile of issues in this
you worship and of course um
questions around the workshops were or
what happens to the
debt of an asset that has been generated
and i would have assumed that any
transfer is not just
the asset but it's a liability
um and and the encouragement of
the powers that be in the steering group
is to
keep up your investment in this area
because at the moment
this is still law where the
lawful owner's office assets haven't got
obligations to meet so
any questions around getting the stitch
on
water treatment upgrades for example uh
really off
off the table we need to carry on with
this and despite
the government talking about a
three-year timetable for implementation
i think most commentators
are thinking that's pretty very
ambitious
um this will take some time and it could
be a big
distraction as we try and do all the
other things while keeping your eye on
the referral
but at this point in time worship i
don't believe there's
any reasons why we shouldn't enter the
mean round of understanding
receive the funds and then step our way
cautiously forward
with eyes wide open
[Music]
the um that money will go into
creational form of capital words i think
that there's
actually some way to reunite
because ultimately you would
think that single government have an
expectation
objective which will be charged it's not
possible for a
rate class to make the standards
required by sending government from
russian
it's it's high time and timely that
government's going to put some money
into this
unfortunately it's going to come with
some restrictions and we may lose it in
control
look
[Music]
i don't think you need to worry too much
council bulger about um
people out reading leaders they've done
electrically and
if you're on your phone um
but i take the point that steve has made
and and cliff's made that
the way we deliver and not just us i'm
talking about local government
in general across the country the way we
do it is obviously broken
because we're not there we're not
delivering
the quality of water that we want to
deliver
most of that comes down to cost so i
think
dead right insofar as potentially
having that money would give us the
ability to uh to do what we needed to do
but again gus bulger said you know
government's not going to give a whole
lot of money and just
as they go away and do it they want to
have some control so there will be some
reform of some sort
i don't know what um that would look
like
but we need to think deeply about
what that what shape that might take
because it has the potential to
completely change um both the
former local government and the role of
local government going forward
uh and i i believe in a more fundamental
way
than the reforms of 1989
so who knows where this is going to end
but we do need to be aware that
as the chief executives pointed out
control of water
is almost giving a blank check to
someone
because you can charge what you like and
everybody needs water
so we need to make sure it's retained in
public ownership
what that public ownership looks like
i'm not sure
personally i'd like to see it as local
as possible
but that may not be the outcome i don't
think we have a choice
in fact i think we'd be silly not to
sign the mou
but we do need to take a very clear and
conscious effort we'll make it fair and
conscious effort to be involved
as time goes on and there will be a
number of meetings along the way
um probably they won't all be held in
goa in fact maybe some of them might be
held in poor but i think
i'll just encourage councillors that if
you
have the opportunity to be part of the
discussions around whatever form
take it um the meeting in invercargill
was
was particularly informative and very
well attended
uh and and i certainly learned a lot and
i know that the counselors that were
there
um learned a lot but open for discussion
counselor phillips
thank you well i'm one that's going to
hear our caution here and i believe that
we should be very cautious about
stepping forward
and putting your signature to this
i can see it going to be a big brother
scenario and that every rapper in the
gore district will end up paying
through that through their water meter
system and it might take 10 years
because they want
cost recovery i'd be very interested
to get them to get
the thoughts of
[Music]
to me
i can see it turning into a needs eta
scenario is that the last one of the
rates will be the only one to get the
money and we are a small council
that's just my thought
and i shouldn't be uh
with the 1.5 million
they don't care it's definitely in front
of us
i take the point you make um council
phillips
bearing in mind there's no there's no
stick with this
particular this is a grant and council
can
as long as it's providing a better water
service can do what it wants
i think as time goes on and we learn
more about what the
opportunities and the hooks are then
we do need to be having the discussions
that you're talking about here we do
need to be wary
um because you're dead right in terms of
what small local government units might
look like in the future
because if by chance
water delivery and water maintenance is
taken out of that role
you know that leaves quite a gap in that
functionality as a council that'll
happen across the country
uh council grant and councillor dixon
[Music]
which i was quite happy to see the water
service delivery arrangements
this is at the top of the page what a
service delivery rates must be
requiring fundamental requirements
[Music]
i guess the point i'm making is that
there's public ownership in public
ownership
what is it what does it look like and we
don't know
but certainly public ownership in my
mind's secrecy
but sometimes that top ownership can be
a very much
arm's length
uh councillor phillips oh sorry council
dixon
yeah council
is the 1.1 million or the two million
people have
gone towards a particular project and
would that mean that we need to be
hiring more staff for that project which
is part of that
through your worship um the expectation
is that
it would be encouraged to spend on
operational
or capital works preferably something
that's uh
it can be dragged forward out of your
long-term plan
um so the hinters you know um water or
wastewater pipeline renewals it lends
itself very well to this
um and it would just be a contract that
we would
let and manage and oversee
in the normal way so obviously
the physical works done by contracting
staff would be a boost to your local
economy
and that's that's certainly to be
encouraged but i don't see
any downsides of uh internal staff
capacity
to be able to deliver and spend this
money well
and the recommendation for you is that
we come up with a deliberate proposed
delivery plan
and we'll identify projects or projects
project or projects
topics are objects that can give effect
to this disease funds
while the government starting intention
is for publicly owned multiple
multi-regional models for this water
service delivery
with the preference for local authority
ownership final decision
where we deliver the models and forward
discussion from the local government
that means that if local government
don't give their way then it will be
private
potentially we're going to go into their
eyes while we're signing in the airport
council um just in regard to if we
actually
uh through your worship to the sign of
the mou what effect does that have
in regard to our long-term ltp that
we're starting to go into the workshop
around
does it bind us to anything we still
have free
free grace around what uh three worship
pretty much free uh and i had
uninhabited ability to develop her own
long-term plan
what i'm literally gonna be doing is
extracting something
out of our current plan that's sitting
in
maybe years four or five or six and
bringing it forward into
year one uh now we have this month um
so i don't think anything that we i'm
busy will come up with would straight
jacket the long-term plan at all
okay um
and then it gets dished out on pro rata
if you can't agree how it goes yeah
three which that's why the suggestion is
the chief executives
get in the room and hammer out a deal
that um
that everyone can live with yeah
[Music]
absolutely this is um i'm pretty sure
this is a slam dunk
2.2 million dollar grant um
you know maybe a bit more depending on
how negotiations go
um and on top of other shove already
money that we have
been confirmed and still some still
to be cons or to be decided uh we're in
the shortlist for
um yeah this is all these
funds are coming to us about
real tags in terms of
[Music]
conditions around minimum contribution
apart from just get on with it and spend
an entirely weight
okay so any further
questions or comments um
this is a pretty significant motion a
sort of a 10-part
motion but i think it's reasonably
straightforward
and hopefully counselors can do their
way through that
is there any alterations required to
those motions you can see
if not somebody like to move that those
motions in total
we put the council ultimate driver's
secondary to that council agreement
is there any further discussion it's not
i'm going to put that motion all those
into over please stay away
the motion is carried um
thank you thank you councillors
okay i think that brings us to the end
of the open agenda
of council today um so
i'll move that
would be excluded from the following
proceedings this meeting
namely items that are listed on page